who's there hello you you sir yes I hope  I don't have what's your name sir  David David lovely Adam where you from  David Australia do you live here now  yes I do I've been sorry you live in  Surrey lovely part of the world  and what he do in Surrey David I design  and build exhibitions so I'm an  exhibitionist really okay when I first  came over to England I had a couple of  interesting moments with the English  accent and I had a blocked ear so I had  to go to the walkabout centre to get out  to get it unblocked and after she'd  flushed my ear the nurse said to me now  I want you to all your ear and your  willy and I said to her and my willy  she said no annually  [Applause]  you